HERE. YEAH HERE IN SALAS
PRESENT JONES SAWYER.
THREE OF US. THANK YOU. SUMMARY
KAMLAGER-DOVE HAS AB FOURTEEN
HUNDRED. SECOND SO I'M NOT
GOING TO WASTE ALL OF YOUR TIME
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED HAS
EVOLVED DURING THIS PROCESS THE
NOW WILL JUST REQUIRE THE
COMMISSION ON HEALTH AND SAFETY
WORKERS COMPENSATION FOR
STUDIES ON A REPRESENTATIVE
SAMPLE FACILITY FOR FIRE
MAINTAINED IN ORDER TO
DETERMINE THE REST OF US
EXPOSURE TO CARCINOGENIC
MATERIALS THE FIRE WE CAN'T
GIVE THEM FROM A NUMBER OF OUR
MECHANICS WHO CONTRACTED CANCER
HAVE DIED MUCH OF IT I PRESUME
TO COME FROM THEIR WORK
ENVIRONMENT. SO WE ORIGINALLY
OR ASKING FOR. LET'S TO THE
INSURANCE AND NOW THIS IS OFTEN
TO A STUDY TO KIND OF CONFIRM
THE DATA THAT THEY'RE GETTING
AND I DON'T. I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WE HAVE A
LOT OF TIME TO KILL ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS CLOUT
WITH ANY TO SAY YES. WITH FIRE
SURVEYS CHAIR. WILL BE GREAT
BUT THESE MEN AND WOMEN THAT
ACTUALLY SERVICE THE EQUIPMENT
THAT WE GO OUT WE GO OUT ALL
THIS PROTECTIVE GEAR THEY COME
IN IT'S COMPLETELY DIFFERENT IN
THE SHOP SETTING AND ACTUALLY
IT'S KIND OF WEIRD WE OVERLOOK
THIS ASPECT OF THE FIRE SERVICE
AS I AM SO EXCITED THIS BILLS.
HERE AND WHAT HOLDEN SUPPORTED
FOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER COMMENT. IF NOT BETTER.
LOS. NO I JUST WANT TO YOU KNOW
SAY SOMEWHERE WHAT MISTER
SHARED IS THAT YOU KNOW THESE
NUMBERS DON'T EVEN HAVE ON
PROTECTIVE MASKS THEY DON'T
HAVE GOGGLES THE WOMEN THAT
THEY DO HAVE TO PROTECT THEM
THEY ACTUALLY BY HOME DEPOT OR
OTHER. STORES LIKE MOST OF THE
FOLKS THAT FOR THEM THE UNIFORM
THAT THEY WHERE I'M DOESN'T GO
THROUGH ANY KIND OF DETAIL
DECONTAMINATION PROCESS SIMILAR
TO FIREFIGHTERS THEY WATCH THEM
IN THE LAUNDRY ROOMS WHERE WE
ARE WATCHING THEIR OWN CLOTHES
AND SO THIS IS A FIRST STEP
INTO HELPING SORT OF SOLIDIFIED
THE ANECDOTAL DATA THAT THEY'RE
SEEING IN DYING FROM. AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ANKLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE SECOND
COLUMN. ALL RIGHT MOTION IS
SEVEN AMENDMENTS HE CONCURRED
IN KALRA AYE KALRA AYE FLORA BY
FLORA. CREEL IDEA YEAH HI
GONZALEZ I CAN SALAS AYE JONES
SAWYER THREE OF US THREE OF US
WHAT THAT BILL WILL BE HEADED
TO THE FOR. IN THE MIDST OF
COMMITTEES ADJOURNED CALLAWAY